the way to get started is to quit
talking and begin doing walt disney
[Music]
fears the disease hustle is the antidote
travis kalanick
the question i ask myself almost every
day is am i doing the most important
thing i could be doing mark zuckerberg
the best time to plant a tree was 20
years ago the second best time is now
chinese proverb
[Music]
i attribute my success to this i never
gave or took any excuse florence
nightingale
the most difficult thing is the decision
to act the rest is merely tenacity
amelia earhart
[Music]
do or do not there is no try yoda
[Music]
twenty years from now you will be more
disappointed by the things that you
didn't do than by the ones you did do so
throw off the bolons sail away from safe
harbor catch the tradewinds in your
sails explore dream discover mark twain
when i let go of what i am i become what
i might be lao zoo
[Music]
the most common way people give up their
power is by thinking they don t have any
alice walker
[Music]
life is what happens to you while you
re-busy making other plans john lennon
[Music]
80 of success is showing up woody allen
build your own dreams or someone else
will hire you to build theirs fairy gray
it is never too late to be what you
might have been george eliot
when everything seems to be going
against you remember that the airplane
takes off against the wind not with it
henry ford
[Music]
you can t fall if you dante climb but
there is no joy in living your whole
life on the ground unknown
[Music]
challenges are what make life
interesting and overcoming them is what
makes life meaningful joshua marine
if you want to lift yourself up lift up
someone else booker t washington
[Music]
formal education will make you a living
self-education will make you a fortune
jim rohn
rarely have i seen a situation where
doing less than the other guy is a good
strategy jimmy spithill
[Music]
your time is limited so dante wasted
living someone else's life steve jobs
the best revenge is massive success
frank sinatra
my biggest motivation just to keep
challenging myself i see life almost
like one long university education that
i never had every day i am learning
something new richard branson
i've a learned that people will forget
what you said people will forget what
you did but people will never forget how
you made them feel maya angelou
[Music]
the two most important days in your life
are the day you were born and the day
you find out why mark twain
[Music]
whatever you can do or dream you can
begin it boldness has genius power and
magic in it johann wolfgang von gouda
[Music]
life shrinks or expands in proportion to
1s courage anise nin
there is only one way to avoid criticism
do nothing say nothing and be nothing
aristotle
[Music]
do what you can where you are with what
you have teddy roosevelt
everything you've ever wanted is on the
other side of fear georgia dare
seven times and stand up eight japanese
proverb
two roads diverged in a wood and i i
took the one less traveled by and that
has made all the difference robert frost
[Music]
i am not a product of my circumstances i
am a product of my decisions stephen
covey
[Music]
it is hard to do a really good job on
anything you don t think about in the
shower paul graham
what is money a man is a success if he
gets up in the morning and goes to bed
at night and in between does what he
wants to do bob dylan
[Music]
a person who never made a mistake never
tried anything new albert einstein
[Music]
the person who says it cannot be done
should not interrupt the person who is
doing it chinese proverb
you can t use up creativity the more you
use the more you have maya angelou
[Music]
you miss one hundred percent of the
shots you don t take wayne gretzky
it always seems impossible until it has
done nelson mandela
[Music]
it does not matter how slowly you go as
long as you do not stop confucius
if you do what you've always done you ll
get what you've always gotten tony
robbins
[Music]
success is walking from failure to
failure with no loss of enthusiasm
winston churchill
you may be disappointed if you fail but
you are doomed if you don t try beverly
sills
[Music]
few things can help an individual more
than to place responsibility on him and
to let him know that you trust him
booker t washington
[Music]
whenever you see a successful person you
only see the public glories never the
private sacrifices to reach them
vibhofsha
remember no one can make you feel
inferior without your consent eleanor
roosevelt
[Music]
the question isn't he who is going to
let me yes who is going to stop me ain
rant
the only way to do great work is to love
what you do steve jobs
[Music]
timing perseverance and 10 years of
trying will eventually make you look
like an overnight success biz stone
[Music]
thanks for watching subscribe to the
channel wisdom of the ages
[Music]
you